hello everyone and a special welcome to
all you dreamers out there today on
versus we're gonna get soaked while
saving Jazz because it's a celebration
of two of the most beloved musicals in
talking picture history we'll put a
favorite from the modern era 2016's Wawa
land against the Hollywood classic and a
sort of ancestor to the land of double
laws 1952's Singing in the Rain oh did I
mention we honor movies here by making
them compete for our Amusement I know I
know it sounds a little cruel but come
on have you seen the movies we're
talking about I've been hosting this
show since Soul Train was in a today and
now finally we get to have a legit dance
battle to determine musical cinematic
superiority if you're like me and in
that case sorry my advice is to get a
dog in Napa lot then you're gonna have a
knee-jerk reaction every time you hear
about a new musical and it goes
something like this ugh I don't like
singing and dancing I want action and
explosions and Ewoks that childish
whining goes on for a few minutes until
the lights go down screen illuminates
and with that first big number boom I'm
Swept Away into a world of imaginative
delight and after afterwards I literally
skip out of the theater reminding myself
to not sprain another ankle I may go in
Kicking and Screaming but when they're
done right musicals can Dazzle and
Inspire us like no other film genre can
and it's hard to find two movies that
fit that build better than singing in
the rain and La La Land
in one corner it's the 1952 legendary
talkie starring Gene Kelly and Debbie
Reynolds that was so inspiring it's now
every dude's go-to move after a first
date and a few drinks to swing around on
a Lamppost even if we're not quite as
graceful in doing so as Mr Kelly and the
other corner it's Wawa land and awards
darling in 2016. there was so
effervescent La drivers didn't seem to
mind a freeway off-ramp being shut down
for a whole weekend it'll be my job as
judge jury and Judy of this show to
somehow figure out which motion picture
is the jauntiest of them all here's how
we'll determine a winner round one box
office round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score round three iconic
moments round four black tie event and
then we'll do a Wild Card round that
could involve anything from the cast
crew or maybe it's just me seeing Which
films dance moves are harder to recreate
In This Very studio if that doesn't seem
like a fair fight I'll remind you that
we do have in case of fire sprinklers it
would be a nice substitute for rain I'll
also remind you that I sweat standing
still so if I'm dancing like a drunk at
a wedding reception my party temperature
might rise high enough to trigger said
fireproofing water system that's
terrible well my crew is now evacuating
I will take this time to encourage you
to comment right now with your favorite
of these two movies is it while I land
or is it singing in the rain or is there
another Musical that you love even more
than this pair maybe one where the hills
come alive or a babysitter shoves sugar
into little kids's mouths By The
Spoonful I'm a big Julie Andrews stand
but Mary's popping from the sidelines
today at Center Stage it's Triple L
taking on essing in the r what that
sounded dirtier than I wanted it to it's
Kelly and Reynolds against Gosling and
stone in the best two on two match up
this side of NBA Jam right here right
now on versus Let's Get It On round one
box office these two movies have been
proven to possess staying power rarely
seen in pop culture even the young pup
Wawa land has quickly become a cultural
Touchstone thanks to its rabid fan base
re-watch ability and the occasional
pricewaterhousecooper mix up and singing
in the rain is still referenced all the
time in movies TV and even music videos
so yeah these two flicks will continue
to be around for ages but in order to be
a household name you had to get us out
of the house first to see your glory on
the big screen film history proves that
you don't necessarily have to be a
blockbusting Juggernaut to be an
all-time classic but that initial surge
certainly does help and approximately 45
years before surge soda hit the open
market good old-fashioned water was
raining down on movie houses Coast to
Coast for it was in March 27th of the
Year 1952 it's Singing in the Rain
opened Nationwide back then the movie
cost about two million dollars to make
and it danced home with over 7 million
bucks but that's 1952 money you could
buy a new Corvette for around three
grand and fill that baby up with gas
that cost about 20 cents a gallon and if
that wasn't a kick in the midsection
enough rent as in your monthly rent oh
my eighty dollars in 1952. my mom
charges me more and I just get to live
in her basement and today money singing
in the rains total equals around 80
million dollars which is solid and let's
not forget it more than tripled its
production cost so that's a big victory
for the Bean counters would it be enough
to top Wildland the film that felt like
a throwback to old-timey Tinseltown did
a lot of modern money exchanging as
September 12 2016 began a box office run
that would total 447 million dollars
worldwide when the music finally stopped
that's boffo for any production
especially one that's about hopes and
dreams and Jazzy shuffling instead of
dinosaurs and robots and robot dinosaurs
remember the Dinobots and Transformers
age of Extinction how much money did
that movie do one billion dollars
Serenity Now wow land appears to be
stepping into the Victory Lane here in
round one especially because it's budget
was only around 30 million dollars so it
made one too many times its production
cost back and Damien chazelle and
Company managed to complete filming in
just 40 days which is biblically short
for such a stellar product take that
Dinobots La La Land stands out as both
Ryan Gosling's highest grossing movie to
date topping his silver medal effort of
Blade Runner 2049 by almost 200 million
dollars and it's Emma Stone's third
highest grosser ever because remember
when she played Gwen Stacy and the
spider kid fell in love over there
despite Dennis Larry's reservations The
Amazing Spider-Man and its sequel
cleverly titled part two both hauled in
over 700 million dollars a piece but
Triple L wasn't Stone and Gosling's
first dance they were also featured
together in two other hit films can you
name them Crazy Stupid Love did 144
million dollars because people really
enjoyed it and Gangster Squad made over
100 million dollars because people
thought they'd really enjoy it man that
movie it might be a bigger travesty than
the Dinobots I'm dying out here in
fairness The Singing in the Rain that
flick didn't get a huge worldwide
release like la la land did but In
fairness to the more recent of the two
lll took advantage of its platform and
now has the highest honor it's yet
received a win in round one of verses
the show so beloved you'd think it was
hosted by Ryan and Emma it's not that
they had been approached about replacing
me we'll see what happens while the land
goes up one to nothing on its much much
older sibling Singing in the Rain
big idea round two Tomato Meter slash
audience score usually I like to open
this round with some slightly snarky
comment like sherry made a bunch of
dough but did anyone like you after they
saw the film that works for something
like a Transformers or a Gangster Squad
but come on we're talking about an
all-time classic and a modern treasure
so I have a feeling that both critics
and audiences were swooning for these
pictures long after the lights went back
up to the veggie garden we go the Tomato
Meter for who wants it first age before
beauty while singing in the
precipitation has years and looks on its
side aging like a fine wine with a full
bouquet a robust finish and a Tomato
Meter score of 100 it's perfect you
can't get higher than that so it joins
fellow Alzheimer's like Toy Story and
the Terminator at 100 really the first
Terminator is that a hundy all right but
can he pull off moves like Gene Kelly or
Donald O'Connor yeah the movie reviewers
were impressed and the RT critics
consensus reads clever incisive and
funny singing in the rain is a
masterpiece of the classical Hollywood
musical top critics Sarah Michelle
Fetters of movie Freak says to put it
bluntly this is one of the funniest
films ever made and the times is Ed
potten says is Singing in the Rain the
finest musical of them all there are
none better in my book that's stupendous
thanks lots of Praise being heaped upon
singing in the rain and with good cause
but how did the audience feel about it I
can't even fake building suspense here
they love it too 95 on the audience
score metric that 100 TM score obviously
tops the filmography for both Stars Gene
Kelly and Debbie Reynolds and for Kelly
it's tied with fellow 100 percenters
Summer Stock and for me and my gal both
of which feature Gene opposite star Judy
Garland as for Debbie she is another 100
flick as well divorce American style
from 1967. and in addition to having a
pretty talented kid named Carrie
Reynolds had been more recently seen in
fresh films like the hilarious mother
the Albert Brooks one not the Aronofsky
um experiment
mother without the exclamation point is
at 88 and Reynolds also voiced the Lulu
in the Rugrats in Paris movie which is
fresh at 76 way to go Tommy Pickles
these are all incredible digits and
really put the pressure on the law land
to hold serve so before we reveal its
final score let's take a look at
director Damien chazelle that guy makes
some damn fresh fare Whiplash is at 94
first man's at 87 and he's credited as a
screenwriter on 10 Cloverfield Lane
which is at 90 percent so where does
Wawa land fit in perfectly wedged at 91
on the Tomato Meter with an 81 percent
on the audience score all told Babylon
has its work cut out to top those
integers the critics consensus reads
Wawa land breeze new life into a bygone
genre with thrillingly assured Direction
powerful performances and an
irresistible excess of heart and our
friend and versatile host interviewer
critic Scott Mance was one of the
earliest champions of this film claiming
that it will connect with people on the
same level as Titanic and we can only
assume he was referring to the boat
movie not the vessel itself Scott loves
him some Triple L as did the audience
and fellow reviewers but singing in the
rain is going to take this round before
we head into the next stage how ever
where does 2016's Love Letter two movies
like Singing in the Rain rank for its
talented Stars Emma Stone only has the
favorite higher on her career Tomato
Meter which checks into 93 and Birdman
is tied with Wawa land at 91 Gosling
also has 93 as his Breadwinner with
drive then he's got half Nelson and the
nice guys alongside Double L land at 91
their other team-ups Crazy Stupid Love
and Gangster Squad are one fresh movie
and one rotten movie can you guess which
one you probably can guess Crazy Stupid
Love is fresh at 79 and Gangster Squad
is 30 rotten should be lucky to be there
you heard it here first Singing in the
Rain is better than Gangster Squad and
it also wins round two easily and ties
the score with La La Land one to nothing
what round three iconic moments and now
we've officially arrived at the meat
portion of the versus sandwich but it
can also be replaced with an impossible
Patty or even some cauliflower buffalo
chicken you do you but you can't have a
tasty Sando without that fun part in the
middle much in the same way that a
musical doesn't really work unless it's
chock full of song and dance numbers I
guess that's why we call them musicals
because you know there's music but the
dance sequences are really what cells
singing in the rain and La La Land we
don't call them danceicles because
um I don't know why it's a good term
there's a fair amount of comedy in these
flicks and the term density it's right
there jump on that patent remember to
kick your Uncle Mark some royalties and
we're all good this round will be won by
the film with the most memorable moments
including those scenes that not even all
the liquid courage in the world would
let me attempt at the next wedding
reception but if someone did pull the
fire alarm here I think I could at least
give the opening credits of Singing in
the Rain ago it's basically our three
stars Gene Debbie and Don strolling in
place and keeping time with their moves
in rain slickers as they're getting
poured on from the heavens it sounds
simple I would fall trying it and it's
the perfect way to charm us into the
vibe of an all-time great movie watching
experience while a land's beginning
however feels like an experience just to
pull off one long iconic shot there's
actually three different takes cleverly
stitched together and that's real
traffic in the background production
just borrowed the 105 and 110
interchanges for a few days and came up
with this gem it's an early lead here
for Wow land and an A-Plus for effort
not just for the dancers but the another
day in the sun crew for nailing those
shots dancing in time is hard enough
imagine having to keep up with a steady
cam or a crane take care of your union
people they're making everybody else
look better while I land might not fit
as a new density category quite as well
as I thought because it does
occasionally issue fancy toe tapping in
favor of developing The Narrative by a
song as is the case with Maya and
Sebastian's theme but it still makes the
crowd ooh and ah and Swoon what's your
name Mia and if the wonderful a lovely
night sequence feels inspired it's
because it was by singing in the rain's
classic title number you simply can't
get better than that Gene Kelly
performed this routine while sick with
103 degree fever Yes you heard that
correctly we had a cinematic Michael
Jordan Flu Game 45 years before MJ's
incredible feat against the Utah Jazz in
the NBA Finals ironic he was playing
against Jazz I don't think Sebastian
would be rooting for the Bulls in that
matchup but then we get Don O'Connor and
Gene Kelly Going the Distance with Moses
supposes it's like the ultimate game of
horse or dance chicken and neither fella
giving an inch but keeping in perfect
time with one another summer montage and
Wawa land Keeps Us invested in the story
and even in Juicy numbers like city of
stars the complex dance moves are
replaced by chazelle Smooth Operator
touch with a cinematography of Linus
sandgren engaging in kinetic action
Gosling and stone have great moves but
they're not world-class dancers like
O'Connor or Kelly and that was the point
Giselle wanted them to look good dancing
but also be the best at their respective
crafts acting and jazzercising and we
see evidence of those talents as well
especially in the spellbinding audition
that Maya pulls off at least give her a
call back yes hi one of my favorite
parts of the land of multiple laws is
Maya's friends egging her on to go out
on the town we've all been there we know
it's a good idea to stay in you already
got your jammies on but when your pal
sing and choreograph a whole routine
just to get you to join them for the
Applebee's 2 for 20 deal you you gotta
go but what gets my ultimate respect in
this round is Debbie Reynolds she had a
background in gymnastics but was such a
young precocious talent that you just
didn't know she could keep up with a
more accomplished fellas in the picture
multiple coaches and grueling eight hour
a day dance sessions paid off just
witness her in the good morning phase
she's just so effervescent and free
you'd never know that homegirl's feet
were bleeding and after they rap she to
get them attended to kind of like when
MJ wore Jordan Ones in 1998 for his last
hurray at Madison Square Garden and I've
reached my NBA reference quota for the
day if we're close now I think Broadway
Melody seals the W here for Singing in
the Rain it's Gene Kelly and Sid
Charisse at their baletic Apex and much
of it is simply done with a pink
backdrop so simple yet it thrusts the
viewer into a dream like trance and ends
up being more powerful than a whole Army
of Dinobots am I my Transformers quota
for the day to one more okay I have an
idea this whole movie costs like two
million dollars which is like one
Dinobot thump tanks empty bro wow wow
land lives up to its type upon repeat
viewings I saw three times in theaters
but Singing in the Rain is one long
iconic moment I'd put it up there
against any movie name your picture put
all the toy stories together singing in
the rain stays in the game and takes the
lead with a win in round three it's two
to one in favor of the wise Elder
yeshikaka round four black tie event
it's only natural that we name around
after fancy clothing after all the
costume changes alone in these two films
keep us invested just in terms of what
are they going to wear next Walter
Plunkett handled the costuming duties
for Singing in the Rain while Mary
zofrus was at the helm for the Wawa land
wardrobe but in this round I'm thinking
less about what our leads were in the
movies and more about those Ultra snazzy
award shows that require threads well
above my means just to gain admittance
you know like the Oscars this feels like
it's going to be another nail biter of a
round by the way don't do that in movie
theaters it feels a little get off my
lawn that's fair but I don't think
biting nails is just the plight of the
young mind gets long and the
temptation's there but come on don't
bite your nails at a movie theater just
think what would my and Sebastian do
well they'd probably get nominated for a
ton of Academy Awards as one would
expect from singing in
singing in what
what Mighty picture of a hundred percent
on the Tomato Meter Fame was nominated
for exactly two Academy Awards how many
did they give out back then four was the
whole ceremony does Bob Hope riffing for
two and a half hours and then saying boy
I guess it's time for some awards Gene
Hagan is wonderful as silent film star
with a distinct voice Lena Lamont in the
film story her voice is dubbed by Debbie
Reynolds as Kathy Selden much to Lena's
dismay and Hagen ended up being the only
performer from the movie that earned an
Oscar nod losing the trophy to Gloria
Graham for the Bad and the Beautiful a
movie that did crush the award show
circuit that year and to be fair High
Noon came out the same year and Gary
Cooper took home the best actor prize
best picture that year was not high noon
it was upset by Cecil B demille's The
Greatest Show on Earth which is 49
rotten on the Tomato Meter just saying
oh did you know Bob Hope actually did
host that year and my impression dead on
don't look it up I nailed it Lenny
Hayden earned the other nomination for
Singing in the Rain for best score but
no wins for that iconic motion talkie
and the door has been open for a while
land and if you know anything about Maya
and sea bass all they need is an
opportunity this is Mia the film earned
loads of Oscar nominations and took home
six statues seven if you ask Warren
Beatty and Faye Dunaway more on that
later for now let's celebrate Emma
Stone's win for best lead actress
chazelle's victory for best director
Linus for best cinematographer Justin
hurwitz and Company for best score and
song and Wawa also took home best
production design Gosling was nominated
for best lead actor losing out to Casey
Affleck from Manchester by the Sea a
film that is decidedly not an uplifting
musical Moonlight took home best picture
honors after
um we'll talk about it later but in
around all about Awards I thought
Singing in the Rain was poised to teach
this young whippersnapper a thing or two
and cruise to an easy Victory but the
land that was came roaring back in round
four gets the win and all of a sudden we
got a tied ball game two to two why Wild
Card round Legacy it all comes down to
this after a sterling comeback from The
Feisty upstart Wawa Land Is there any
World in which a film from 2016 could
possibly have forged A Lasting
Impression in our Collective
Consciousness that would approach the
reverence we all have for Singing in the
Rain after all rain has been around
since my dad was a baby and in that time
it's become known as one of the greatest
musicals ever and one of the finest
films in history regardless of genre but
if we're talking Legacy La La Land does
have a case that can put forth so you
remember how Singing in the Rain didn't
do all that much to the Oscars well its
descendants sure did and I'm not just
talking about the awards at one one of
the biggest kerfuffles in Academy
history happened that night when Warren
and Faye announced the winner for best
picture was La La Land The Crowd Goes
Wild People hug Scott Mance runs through
the streets of LA like Ebenezer Scrooge
waking up a new man on Christmas morning
but on his way to buy the fattest Goose
at The Forum a funny thing happened a
producer noticed that the card did not
say Wawa land it was actually reading
moonlight
are you kidding me that was your real
Best Picture Winner and deservedly so I
still Harbor my conspiracy theories
about how that all transpired much in
the same way you'll still hear grumbles
from teams not named the New York Knicks
about the 1985 draft order when they won
the right to select Georgetown Legend
Patrick Ewing thanks to an envelope that
may have been frozen oh right I already
hit my NBA quota for the day Google
Frozen envelope it's a fun rabbit hole
look the Oscars had declining ratings
everyone loves a spectacle it's on the
same network that does reality TV like
The Bachelor was Tom Fuller a foot maybe
not but for me the legacy of that Oscars
night especially in the context of more
recent Academy ceremonies is the
sportsmanship displayed by everyone
involved the lava land folk recognized
the air cleared it up on stage in the
moment giving Moonlight its opportunity
and Moonlight graciously accepted and
for a Time shared the stage with the
people who thought they won it was a
nice moment in the eye of a confusion
storm while I had also proved that
musicals are as Timeless at the box
office as they are in our hearts when
done well these puppies can still pack
theaters for months on end not with
superheroes or lightsabers or Dinobots
but simply with song dance and a Little
Tenderness I also love that Damien
chazelle chose Ryan Gosling and Emma
Stone because they weren't professional
dancers they had some game to be sure
but that could have been any one of us
they weren't Jean or Don or Fred Astaire
which leads me to a part of singing in
the Reigns Legacy Debbie Reynolds worked
tirelessly to keep up with her scene
Partners so much so that she exhausted
herself multiple times and at one point
felt so hopeless about mastering a
routine that she laid her tired body
under a piano and wept thinking nobody
was there who happened to be walking by
Fred frickin Astaire the dance Legend
asked her why so blue and right there on
the spot he cheered her up and gave her
a free dance lesson Reynolds got back in
the game and the rest is history during
rain delays at Pittsburgh Pirates PNC
Baseball Park they play The Rain Song
sequence performed by Gene Kelly one of
that Town's all-time favorite Sons but
more so than any yarn or factoid or even
seen in the film singing in the rain has
earned its status among Hollywood
royalty because of the way it makes us
feel why light happy Airy like the world
is new and full of possibilities even
when it's pouring outside we can sing
through it because of what's inside of
us at the end of the day the music in
our ears and the movement on screen
belies the efforts put forth by the cast
and crew I can't tell that Debbie
Reynolds just learned some of these
steps or that Gene Kelly is having a
sick game in dance shoes instead of Air
Jordans Wawa land has a similar way of
encouraging us to pursue our passions
even if the expense of a love that could
have blossomed but for Singing in the
Rain to still be relevant at all much
less an influential Force to films like
La La Land in the modern era is just too
much Legacy to ignore Triple L ain't
going away anytime soon but singing in
the rain has already etched a permanent
place in Tinseltown war and in our
hearts the Elder takes the win in the
Wild Card round and thus gets the
victory over a very game opponent
actors I'm much good at speaking in
public so we'll just act out our thanks
hey we signed into the Oscars Miss
direct of declaring la la the winner and
then correcting myself as I signed off
we've all been through enough and if you
feel like you've been through enough
this week for this month or even this
life toss on either sing into the rain
or wild wild land and it's a time-tested
remedy that will have you back tapping
your toe in rhythm in no time flat
thanks for watching this episode of
versus what's your favorite musical of
all time hit me up Mark Ellis live and
hit us up at Rotten Tomatoes as always
thanks for tuning in I'm your host Mark
Ellis and I'm gonna go find a Lamppost
to hug
is that how they I'll work on it
[Applause]